agora
boa tarde a todos antes de mais quero
dar os brancos para uma festa
maravilhosa equipa pelo trabalho pelo
incentivo e pelos resultados que nem a
planta não fez frente acho que as
mulheres tenham salva de palmas
poxa das últimas tem as suas vantagens
apanha de longe dos outros e isso vai
ajudar a descobrir um caminho longo e é
dada do que entrada aqui mas eu queria
contar por dever descobrir os hoje é
precisamente ver as diferentes
perspectivas comigo 12 nenhum é
provavelmente a minha nova está lá a
haver esta manhã que descobriu seu poder
ter em um determinado sítio a
possibilidade de outra ilha idéias que
vale a pena acreditar temos que
trabalhar com paixão e acreditar sempre
lutar até o fim
isto porque e eu aqui só trazer o que os
a equipa do tek fotogradada partilhou eu
acredito apaixonadamente que as terras
não pela qual estamos aqui hoje
a idéia é pensar no início o filho e
qual foi o meu ponto de partida é a anp
mais eu iniciei eu gosto muito de
crianças depois tirar o meu curso
percebi que era isso que eu queria fazer
sou apaixonada pelo livro do prémio
exemplo muitos de vós provavelmente o
cliente tem e gostaria de partilhar a
uma frase que é dada à as
características da fala não é possível
ver muito vai pedir desculpa
cada um passa na nossa vida passa
sozinho mas não vai só - deixa eu só
levo um pouco de nós do que nós mesmos
deixa um pouco de si mesmo
anthony e nós fomos vendo ao longo de
todas as representações comissão da
verdade como
um dos lotes como também ao estado
anteriores tem estas características ano
outro ponto partilhas conseguir parar na
cara desta criança que equipes apresenta
e pedido a vossa partida para um
aspectos se vos perguntar o que é que
faz lembrar tivessem que identificar uma
palavra para identificar a criança por
favor partilhem conosco com a palavra
sexo poderiam nessa nossa aprovação
andria ocorra órion
mas a curiosidade vida
estas são algumas que vamos fazer com
que eles vão fazer pensar por que é tão
importante
vamos ver outros pontos de partida e
aqui vamos ter um pequeno vídeo porque
não vai mais facilmente as crianças
demonstram isso vamos viver agora vamos
pensar vamos fazer um jogo que vamos
fazer as caras das palavras que ela
fizer tudo certo vamos imaginar que
estamos na escola
vamos imaginar que estamos no hospital
vamos lá imaginar que estão doentes
estamos contentes e e que vamos brincar
grande sorriso
olha eu acho que se o brinquedo no
hospital não expresso brincar a brincar
a gente brincava e era bom
bom acho que era mais fácil
também não deixe também a verdade este
efetivo um efetivamente um dos pontos de
partida
todos nós já tivemos a possibilidade de
entrar em um hospital e é nossa primeira
opção é que está tudo branco tudo frio
com sons pessoas desconhecidas para uma
criança com estas características e com
todas aquelas que nós tivemos a falar
isso não faz muito sentido que era isso
que eu achava
então quando você trabalha que teria uma
criança implicavam vestir a roupa do
europeu quando os jogos de futebol e que
estava internada e tenham direito de ver
o jogo e sentir o jogo da mesma forma e
de vivenciar esta esta situação de forma
diferente mas não era como não era hora
com nove ministros não era o energia
toda a gente não fazia sentido quando
tive a possibilidade de ir fazer o
mestrado em letras da imagem gastar e
tendo em conta as características dos
açores que é preciso fazer em parceria
com a universidade do porto
queremos pensar qual era automática do
da nossa da nossa pesquisa
a minha única coisa que não fazia mais
importante é que não se brinca no
hospital porque não se brinca mais
parecia uma lógica criança brincar é
então essa foi o início para utilizar a
usar com um fio
o brinquedo terapêutica em pediatria
isso porque a criança contigo hospital
jardim algumas das características que
esta filho não ia ter ninguém estou
assustado isto acontece com os adultos
com as crianças ainda mais
então somando deles é brincar isso
trabalho deus é brincar porque não fazê
lo desta forma então a idéia foi criar
uma intervenção em que as crianças
quando os gatos no hospital
além de todos os aspectos que quem teve
já essa essa situação presente sabe
brinquedos
diga uma coisa quantos de vós porque vós
ram podem pôr um no ar quanto gostam mas
temos muitos não é que os outros não
compreendo forma alguma claro que não
nós sabemos o quanto o som quanto custa
vez preto os nossos filhos
então eu fiz quando chegaram ao hospital
em desfazer a todo o comprimento natural
e apresentar o serviço que foi feito foi
utilizado brinquedo utilizado livros
adaptados à idade da criança porque a
criança equipe entrar no hospital de uma
forma mais relaxada diminuir o tempo de
treinamento melhora mais rapidamente
sai mais rapidamente do hospital e isto
uma visão economista é também muito bom
e é importante é isso que nós queremos é
então vamos trazer
vou precisar da ajuda do andré 35 anos
que agora já tem certa
as crianças quando chegavam em vez nós
de explicar os efetivamente se vai haver
uma equipa médica uma equipa de
enfermagem que eles vão conhecer o
serviço e que vão ter a diversos
instrumentos com os quais tranqüilidade
que não conhecem no seu dia a dia porque
trabalhou com a linha 'boneca' isso não
acontece
então seremos um dia seremos os
respectivos médicos informantes e assim
quando tivessem de explicar a razão pela
qual eles precisariam ser condicionados
para aplicar o soro
assim é mais difícil explicar se fossem
o prato quem efectivamente perceber
porque é que os medos que os informantes
são todos iguais
vestem todos e todas todas e outras
batas e passam a ser todos iguais mas o
estudante porque não saber que ela está
um dos links da intervenção diziam
a mãe declarou patrícia liz mais uma
coisa que é vieira mãe preocupada quando
ela acordou da cirurgia parece o jogo
entre o benfica eo porto é entre o
sporting e peço desculpa entre o
sporting eo porto porque era um
estudioso e outros de van e sim em estar
em todos os problemas em todas as dores
que diminuído de estar a pensar no jogo
entre a equipa do imm
não estou que a anunciar nenhuma equipa
futebolística mas efetivamente é esta
situação a informarem terceira patrícia
neste caso queria fazer a intervenção
era uma boneca que estava vestida tudo
igual e tenha mais um mínimo a minha tal
e qual as portas da pediatria então em
vez de eu explicar a razão pela qual
essa quantia
eu tenho uma possibilidade de funcionar
a meta de experimentar na boneca em vez
de sermos nós os autos os atores são
eles o que prevê sempre mais próximos ou
tomar o domínio da situação e também
podiam escolher uma coisa para os
usuários nem sempre dizem como é que se
sentem obrigados a fazer
eles vêm sempre nos dizem como é que 60
então não podiam escolher estão
contentes
é tão triste mesmo não vivendo
efetivamente a razão como é que seria
assim tão lógica às vezes só queria se
orientaram as pedras pequenas coisas às
vezes não muito mais valorizadas do que
as grandes coisas
não é preciso muito para fazer uma
intervenção destas já vão estar temos
muitas opções à nossa disposição
então depois não há outra situação nos
depoimentos não ser um dos membros da
prefeitura de brumado marco é favor que
não vai faltar empenho a possibilidade
de alguém não sou nominal e mandou a
procurar o meu pai assim interior que é
amor chapa que os desenvolvem que ajudem
- e esta foi uma visita à pediatria do
hospital riomar mostrou como é dirigir
aliás obviamente ram não dá para ver
muito bem mas podem virar os juízes das
cargas das mais de cem primeiras das
crianças durante esta situação
é isso que elas estão doentes não
precisam ficar mais triste com a
situação a partida existe trabalho
fechou a todo o desenvolvimento da
intervenção no bolso tribunais
apresentou fugindo à formalidade
no fim que está tudo adiantado fugir à
formalidade e ponto todos jurídico de
maio
a fotografia quanto do jeito que eu
evitasse até um livro o que na altura
estava em dúvida a nossa insularidade
são os clientes a não faz tem que estava
em ok vocês vão dizer só pôde ver em
altura não valoriza esta esta situação
até que percebi que não era sempre assim
até que temos de positivo à proposta por
parte da editora do continente
a usaf ânsia de fazer a edição do livro
nessa altura já era contadora de
histórias pela fundação do gil que
ganhava janela as crianças na pediatria
do hospital em que nós cá já temos e já
tem uma relação muito mais presente com
o profissionalismo mas tendo em conta
andré 2 a 3 no shopping que já tinha
estado ficar não faria sentido é editar
um livro que ajudar essas crianças
hospitalizadas porque este não é só a
profissionalização depois pais que
tiveram crianças 20 após os pais querem
saber como podem ajudar o seu filho é
melhor para as crianças então uns livros
parte da festa do livro versa a favor
destas ambas as instituições
o carlos outro dia na apresentação dia
que uma das razões pelas quais este ex
ponta delgada estava com a mãe era a
equipa eu acho que nós fizermos as
coisas bem acompanhados com paixão e
recebendo aquilo que nós queremos três
coisas correm mal às mil maravilhas com
isso que aconteceu mais uma coisa o
carlos também falou das dificuldades
temos muitas
temos muito dinheiro
em grandes e muitas instituições e
queríamos deixar passar 11 idéia luta
encontra todas as batalhas que
desaparecem porque elas vão aparecer
tivemos muitas dificuldades o caminho é
esta edição do livro coincidiu com um
diagnóstico de doença crônica meu quem
deixou muito limitada e com diagnóstico
do moço não vivem da minha mão
isso para dizer que eu fiz as correções
sentada quando a minha mãe saiu da
cirurgia e quando acabei o quando o
livro estava finalizado foi quando nós
estávamos no continente a fazer
radioterapia por casinhas trazem esses
mesmos temos que sair e mesmo assim está
a ser tão batalhada as coisas têm mais
sentido tem muita equipe de amigos a
capa foi o artista é o andré neste caso
está perfeita com andré irá da turquia
pelo pai
a edição é de 1 30 visão é dos amigos
tudo foi feito como o caso do dia 8 vai
ter uma equipa da mix ou muito muito bem
aqui como estava a dizer quando acabou
quando foi buscar na altura quando
estava em radioterapia com a minha mãe
achei que o meu marido e meus filhos
deram lugar à minha mãe que seria um
papel importante com a filha ficaram
livre pra mim não fazer rock
mas para ela era muito importante é a
primeira vez que viu me ataca não é
possível nós temos as mesmas
possibilidades de fazer tudo o que não
faria sentido apresentar sem ter alguns
dos colaboradores
um colega meu de enfermagem a une além
de ser um amigo estudante exemplo é o da
fundação do gil e assim foi
estes foram alguns dos momentos toda a
gente em pé a fazer pelas 15 mensagens
nos outros porque foi o membro da
personagem do - trouxe e margarida pinto
correia com muito agrado
vieram pra que pagar juros aquilo que
quer fazer sorrir as crianças sejam
instrumentos médicos contadores de
histórias
aliás a mix mas temos todos a
possibilidade de os verdes enquanto
docente e também que algumas pessoas
necessárias
é é também importante por fora palavra e
fazer ver aos outros resultados aos
nossos estudantes que é possível e é
nessa altura que tem 32
na altura os exemplos são muitos os bons
e os maus
e se não tiverem postinho o bichinho não
virem resultando com as coisas têm que
acontecer será mais difícil que está a
tapa e não queria deixar acabar saindo
dizer do im
embora no meio de nós queria deixar de
ler esta frase a arte deve permanecer
mas só em todas as crianças acham que
estas não precisam de máscaras por isso
utilizamos a menor máscara do mundo no
egito pagasse atendimentos de corte e
mais revela como verdadeiros artistas e
às vezes é tão fácil basta
obrigada